Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
I know that blank wall bothers you, I just
can't think of what to do with it.
If I move the camera over here, there's too
much light.
I guess I could just zoom in, but then my
face looks weird.
I can do this angle; this is a nice angle
for me, but it's a little nostrily.
I think I'm just going to go to the airport.
I know how to make videos there.
And here we are, Hank, I gotta tell you, my
boundless enthusiasm for airports, it's a
little bounded at the moment.
By the way, Hank, if you haven't noticed,
I have completely stopped caring what the
people in the airport think of me.
I live here now; this is my residence.
So, Hank, the question I'm asked most often
these days is "Will the Paper Towns movie
be like the book?"
only I don't think they're saying it like
that exactly, I think they're saying it more
like, "Will the Paper Towns movie be exactly
like the book?!", or at least that's how I
hear it in my head.
The answer is yes, the Paper Towns movie is
like the book.
But also, you know, no it isn't.
So Hank, when I was a kid, I was really into
novelizations.
Books that were adapted from TVs or movies
I liked.
I was particularly into "The Goonies" novelization.
For those of you who haven't been blessed
by the magic of "The Goonies", it was a movie
about a bunch of kids who, to save their home,
kind of like discover a pirate ship.
It's awesome!
And the thing I love so much about reading
"The Goonies" novelization, was that it was
like watching the movie in the sense that
all the stuff that happened in the movie,
happened inside my head.
But the novelization felt like fresh and exciting
and new in a way that the movie couldn't,
because I'd already see it like a gajillion
times.
So, because I knew the movie so well, I noticed
all the little changes in the novelization;
like the novel is written from the first person
point of view of one kid and that necessitated
like some moving around of stuff and some
changes in dialog.
And Hank, I loved that!
I loved trying to figure out why the writer
had made changes to the movie in order to
make the story work as text.
Images and sounds just kind of work on us
differently than text does; like one of the
things I love about text-based stories is
that we sort of make them up with the writer.
Because the images that are described in the
text only exist inside of my head while I'm
reading.
Like Hank, my Harry Potter is different from
your Harry Potter, and every other Harry Potter
on the planet.
My Harry Potter is just mine.
But anyway, what I really want from an adaptation
is to feel the feelings I felt while reading
the book, right?
And personally, I'm willing to sacrifice a
lot of plot points to make that happen, like
when I wrote my own screenplay of "Paper Towns"
many years ago, it was vastly different from
the book.
Like Q ends up chasing after a different girl.
Also, there was an airplane crash; it was
just bananas.
Anyway, all I wanted was to find a way to
visually tell the story that when you put
people on a pedestal, when you fail to imagine
them complexly, it's tremendously destructive.
Now, it turns out that relentlessly focusing
on theme instead of story telling is a bad
strategy which is why that screenplay was
so horrible, but the "Paper Towns" script
that Mike Weber and Scott Neustadter wrote,
the same guys who wrote "The Fault in Our
Stars" screenplay, is just brilliant because
it finds a way to capture both the story and
the ideas.
At least for me, when I watched it, the story
created the same feelings and the characters
had the same relationships with each other,
and the same failures to imagine each other,
and also Santa, complexly.
That said, Hank, if you look for differences,
you'll definitely find lots of them.
Like, for instance, there's no Sea World in
the movie because no one was anxious to pay
Sea World for the chance to give them good
publicity.
Instead, the stuff that happens at Sea World
in the book happens elsewhere in the movie.
Also, there's significantly less textual analysis
of Walt Whitman in the movie, which I'm sure
will be disappointing to many.
Don't worry, there's still some, though.
Also, there's some changes that I think are
just better.
Like in the movie, the character Angela joins
in on a road trip that she isn't part of in
the book.
And I like that decision.
I wish I'd made it eight years ago.
And that's another thing I've learned from
"The Goonies" novelization, Hank, changes
are not necessarily for the worse.
In the end, I'd rather have "Paper Towns"
be good than be faithful.
But I genuinely believe it is both.
So I'm just very grateful to the people who
made it.
I feel very lucky.
Hank, your tour is done, congratulations!
I hope you sleep for like three straight days.
And then I hope you wake up, because you have
to make a video on Friday.
I'll see you then.